you're the type of patient that many of
us doctors are terrified of because
you you've been through all this so you
have all this
collected trauma you have a complex
medical condition that we don't fully
understand but we think we do but we
want to feel like we do so we reduce it
to receptors and pills and so on but
we've not seen the full biopsychosocial
thing because it's complicated and we
don't get paid for that we don't have
the time for that and
for that reason you're a challenge to us
that
hurts us morally because we want to help
you when we know we can't
welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
episode 85.
on this episode i am joined by z dog dr
zubin damania i wanted to talk to dr z
because i have a lot of alternative
health professionals on my podcast
and you guys know how i feel about most
mainstream medical doctors
however i'm also aware that because of
my experience i am very biased
i think dr z falls right in the middle
of my more alternative view
and the mainstream medical view the alt
middle
we had a fantastic conversation i
actually had a lot of fun with this guy
we spoke about the virus what a proper
response for nursing homes could have
looked like
different vaccines across the world mrna
vaccines vaccine passports
touched on my health struggles the
impacts of various diets the importance
of skepticism and more
z-dog md is an american physician
assistant professor comedian internet
personality and musician
if you enjoy this content please hit
subscribe
this episode is brought to you by true
local trulocal.ca
use codemp for free stakes who doesn't
love free stakes
you may have heard me talk about this
company multiple times for a while
because they basically sponsor every
health episode
because they're great but i was using
them even before they sponsored my
podcast
with trulocal you choose what goes in
your box and they send it to you
they have any meat you could possibly
want some organs the meat is super high
quality
what true local does is they connect
with local farmers so you get to buy
farmed meat
sustainable nutritious tastes great not
the typical meat you'd find at your
local grocery chain
that comes out of giant slaughterhouses
an added benefit is you get an amazing
product while at the same time
supporting local farmers
if you want to get healthy incorporating
more meat into your diet is
literally the easiest way to do it go to
trulocal.ca and use code
mp for free steaks i hope you enjoy this
conversation
zubin welcome to my podcast uh can we
start off by
you giving anyone who's listening who
doesn't know you a bit of a background
about who you are and what it is
you do absolutely and thanks for having
me on by the way uh it's a real thrill
um
so i'm i'm uh i i'm a kid
born from immigrant parents from india
but they're like this ancient persian
ancestry they're both doctors so i had
no
choice i ended up becoming a doctor went
to ucsf medical school and then
stanford for my residency practiced
inpatient hospital medicine for 10 years
really i'm going to use the very
stigmatizing term burnout
suffered that uh woke up started putting
videos on youtube under an alter ego
called z dog md that became a thing
uh moved to las vegas worked with the
ceo of zappos
built a clinic that utilizes something
we call health 3.0
and now i have an internet show called
the z dog md show that
we talk about anything that we can from
a rationalist
alt middle perspective so that's more or
less my story
okay alt middle i like it uh
i want to talk about well
some of the things i want to talk about
we should just get out of the way i want
to talk about covid
because that is what everybody is
talking about right now
and i just came from toronto
which uh is under a new lockdown even
though the old lockdown didn't end
and currently there's a stay-at-home
mandate and you're not supposed to see
family
and i've heard rumors of stopping travel
in between cities within the province
so ontario's been hit really really hard
with restrictions and
um i had coveted last july uh
and i've been i i guess
you'd call me i've been an outspoken
critic against
government-mandated restrictions they've
put in
so i'd probably fall more on what the
news would call the right
perspective on kovid but i wanted to get
you on
uh to get your opinion on a whole bunch
of things so
first off can we start with how
dangerous do you believe covet is
well you know i'll say this first of all
michaela by questioning government
mandates you are basically murdering
grandma so you're a horrible person
and i'm going to judge you like
everybody on twitter will judge you
uh okay just get that out of the way uh
so as you can tell i'm
a little biased probably in your
direction
so okay okay so your question was how
dangerous do i think covet is
or what yeah um
this is such a nuanced question and yet
we have to
you know we have to present it as i also
i also was like is it how dangerous is
it period
just like no direction there but uh go
ahead
no but i love it because that's that's
the question that the public
wants to know right so why can't we
answer that properly
and and i this is how i conceive of this
it that that question has an answer
for you it does not have an answer for a
population it doesn't have an
answer for everybody it has an answer
for you and
it depends on how old you are what your
other diseases are
how likely you are to contract covid how
much on the front lines you are
and your own risk tolerance so how much
are you willing to
take risks like when you get in a car
you're
a young person you know in your 20s
a 24 year old and younger is 36 times
more likely to die of a car accident
than they are
of covid so for them covet is much less
dangerous than for a 65 and older who
they're twice as likely to die of covet
than of a car accident
but what we've done as a as a policy is
we've not acknowledged that
so we do all the backwards things we
shut our schools down
we shut down everything we stop travel
between
cities i mean this what you're saying
they're doing in canada is crazy and
this is nuts because that
yeah yeah but do you think it's actually
happening
i read an article suggesting it was so i
would assume yes
but we'll see in the next couple weeks i
mean if they prevent
getty lee and alex leifsen from leaving
toronto uh
to to tour the members of rush then i
will become violent um
i'd be okay with that as long as i'm out
of toronto
[Laughter]
so um you know this this idea of
then having a a different answer for is
it dangerous for different
subsets of people means you have to have
a different response for different
subsets of people so
what we've done is we've closed schools
dumb because you're looking you if
you're a hammer everything's a nail
right so if you're
a person who's worried about covid
specifically then you're going to shut
down schools thinking well we might drop
a little bit of the transmission even
though kids don't transmit it so
aggressively the new variants maybe a
little bit more but not that much
and what we don't look at the downside
of shutting schools which is
a regressive tax on poor people like
it you you and i like we're
communicating by zoom right now
we're in the democracy we're the laptop
barati
right we can survive and thrive
in this world but the kid whose mom is
an essential worker
cannot they need school they need school
for structure they need it for meals
they need for education they need it for
a path
out so that they can actually express
their true authentic self in the world
and what the
laptop eradi have done the public health
apparatus and our governments and
and a lot of people are complicit in
this that they said you know what
yeah we can go ahead and shut down
because i can still make a damn good
living in fact i might do
better in this world when i don't have
to commute and see bob in the office and
have him cough on me
and and and that's why i think this
question of like is kova dangerous the
answer is yes in the sense that it's
dangerous to
what we've done to ourselves as a
society we haven't
targeted our um our restrictions
in a way that's going to protect
vulnerable people we've harmed those
vulnerable people and we still have
huge numbers of infections and deaths so
we suck
at this honestly
okay okay i agree
with that bit of a rant no no that was
good i've definitely ranted about this
before i thought that
the people who got hit are the people
who are are losing their jobs
not making very much money not the
people who are like yeah okay i'll take
a couple months
a year stay at home like i have an
office job that'll pay me
or i'm on zoom you know it's not then
those are the people who are in charge
of saying yeah this is what we'll do for
everyone
because they're so removed from the
people who have to go out
and work all day it's like it's like dr
evil
is making the rules for everyone you
know and this guy is not a normal guy
like he's a bald dude with a mini-me who
sits there going you know i have summers
in rangoon
you know in spring we made meat helmets
uh everybody needs to shut down
so i can sit here and pet my cat and
still make a lot of money
the wealth and equity has actually
gotten worse during
covet now this is what kills me so when
you think of this from an
alt-middle perspective and alt middle is
something that
we came up with that is simply says you
say yes and to
all ideas you assume good intent and
then you start to pick them apart and
critically think for yourself
so you're not an id your data said this
never
be an ideological purist i forget the
term he uses he calls it um
there was a term he used in other words
if you say you're a liberal
don't just check all the boxes like well
then that means i
don't want uh i'm pro-choice and i'm
this and that no no you can be a complex
think for yourself human being that just
thinks critically on each issues based
on your own moral palate
so this idea of alt-middle is don't have
that ideological purity
think be open-minded be critical be
integral in your thinking so you
sort of integrate all these perspectives
and don't assume the world is divided
into good and bad people
it's actually much more nuanced than
that so the
um the kind of all middle
you know perspective on this is well
liberals ought to be
outraged at how we've hurt the poor like
we have destroyed the poor it is a
disease of now
poor minorities they're the ones who die
and we sit at home
tisking well you need to wear then two
masks maybe it's your fault that you got
covered
[ __ ] off like can i say that on the show
is that okay yes are you kidding me
that's the most patronizing
condescending
classist elitist [ __ ] and
the the left ought to understand that
that's what you're supposed to be
against
and then the right says well you're not
telling me what to do no matter what and
it's like well but
sometimes we need to think a little more
as a community and go well
how can we protect our nursing home
people that means that we all have to do
a little part like if you go into a
supermarket you should probably wear a
mask because there's old people shopping
there
all right fine we can have these
compromises but we see the world in
black and white and i think that's
been very damaging and it doesn't help
that the media fans those flames
okay um one comment i really like how
you transition from
uh dr evil to normal person speaking
voice
so easily like you must have done that a
lot
that was my takeaway there no formal
training just you know
the details of my life are quite
inconsequential
okay um back to kovid
what do you think the proper response
would have been for
nursing homes like should they have
it's been really like it's been really
awful with people
separated from their loved ones and um
saying that that well that's for your
own safety but not giving people the
option in ontario
there was at least one nursing home that
actually locked and removed
doorknobs from patients with covet who
were in the nursing home to stop them
from leaving i don't know if they had
alzheimer's or what their reasoning was
because there couldn't be any but
removed doorknobs and nobody found out
about it because people couldn't go in
to see their loved ones
that this is like one of those saw
horror movies
you know like you're stuck in a nursing
home and they take the doorknobs out
and you have a little bit of dementia
and you're disoriented and you're on 13
psychotropic medications because the
doctors don't know what to do with you
and you're bouncing off the walls and
then they take your one source of
orientation away
and listen you can you can you can make
a distinction between the early pandemic
when we didn't have enough ppe when our
staff were dying when they were like
keep visitors out of here and so on okay
that's one thing we didn't know what was
happening everybody was terrified
we know better now and what we're doing
is perpetuating a human rights violation
this is a human
rights violation telling people they
can't see their loved ones
unless they're on hospice and that by
the way forces people to go on hospice i
mean
it is coercion it's inhuman
healthcare professionals feel it we feel
it as a kind of moral conflict the kind
of injury because we're seeing these
people die alone and we're holding up
the phone so that they can skype i mean
this is absurd it's we're going to look
back at this and there's going to be
documentaries made like schindler's list
style where we go
oh my god what did we do to these poor
people
there are fates worse than death there
are fates worse than death and yeah
wasted them on people so yes i'm with
you i think the answer for the nursing
home thing
in my mind would have been this uh
yes focus on getting them ppe and
and mass and protection uh and
the second thing is give paid leave
for any of their staff that get sick
because what people don't realize is
nursing home staff a lot of them
are lower level pay grade people they're
the same essential workers that we talk
about getting screwed in all this
they can't miss a day of work if they
have a cough or they feel a little fever
they're going to come in because they
can't get paid hide it potentially
yeah pay them to stay home then and then
you you you can help people a lot
they are understaffed they they
themselves suffer it's
a horrible situation and then and you
know what's happening now michaela is
i'm getting messages from
nursing home doctors who are telling me
you got to talk about this
now that the staff and the patients are
all vaccinated
they are still instituting these
ridiculous rules
even though the data shows that with
vaccination you're pretty much
done right nobody will say that in
public health because like well you know
but
if one person dies who's vaccinated
that's that's safety creep no the
vaccines are the answer
that's why like you this idea of
shutting down cities and doing lockdowns
shut the hell up and vaccinate people
who want to be vaccinated don't coerce
it who want to be vaccinated and
will be done with this that's just it
uh so i'm in dubai right now and
it it's crazy i've never been here
before uh it's
it's crazy out here but vaccine wise um
you can go anywhere if you live here i
believe it's free
most people have been vaccinated they're
thrilled about it and you can go
into like doctors offices and things and
just get the vaccine it doesn't matter
who you are
and if you do blood tests to monitor i
just talked to somebody about this you
do blood tests to monitor your antibody
level
and then you can get boosters until your
antibody level stabilizes
and it's something that's just
implemented in abu dhabi
i think it's something like 80 80
something percent
of them are vaccinated and in canada
nobody under the age of 55 at the moment
can get it this one guy i talked to got
his first
vaccination last august i was like we
didn't even know a vaccine existed then
like how is it that there are areas of
the world that are
so far ahead of north america
when we grow up learning at least i grew
up learning like this is the best place
on earth we have the best medical system
in the entire world
which is a total lie oh that's a lie i'm
traveling around
that's all yeah right yeah oh yeah that
but
what like what what's going on
yeah so i think the rest of the world
has a different tolerance for risk
so they say you know what yeah the
thing's good enough let's go sign up
okay russian vaccine in america we're so
litigation averse we're so afraid of
being sued and canada's probably very
similar maybe to a different degree
um we in america particularly we have a
very fragmented healthcare system so you
can't even coordinate
distribution of vaccine which was a
problem early on it's getting better but
it is definitely a problem
early on and i understand like when
you're vaccinating healthy people
the the danger of causing harm is
actually big because
you vaccinated a thousand healthy people
that are low risk for covet and
three of them die those three never
would have died of covid
were we're now creating a problem so you
have to be cautious but not insane
but the interesting thing so you look at
like for example a canada
now we have the astrazeneca vaccine now
it just
i've done a few shows on astrazeneca now
the the two mrna vaccines
um pfizer and moderna i've never seen
data that looks this good like it's
ridiculous they're so safe and effective
you look at johnson and johnson
single-dose vaccine looks
really good right maybe a little less
effective but even that is kind of
plus or minus because it's complex
but astrazeneca the difficulty here is
and this is why science actually works
so even if you have a certain risk
tolerance you have to
look at it and go oh what's going on
here with astrazeneca millions of people
vaccinated
and they start to catch a few very rare
cases
of deep venous thrombosis so blood clots
in unusual places the or sinus of the
brain
the splenic vessels of the gut these
things hardly ever happen
and what they're finding is they're
happening in younger women and we don't
know if they're on birth control which
increases your risk of clotting
um but they're happening in people like
you and the the
question then is in what in what
incidents are they happening
very tiny so you could still make a case
if you're looking at risk and go
yeah but from a risk benefit standpoint
if astrazeneca was the only vaccine we
had well you could you should probably
still get it because your risk of covet
is higher in most people but if you're a
woman on oral contraceptives maybe not
so you can
start to stratify but the great thing
about the covet situation is we've
thrown so many resources at vaccines
that we could actually say
you know what um we have other choices
for young women and for people that
societies that can afford the more
expensive vaccines and so on
so we can then start to parse out risk
there's no one-size-fits-all
and i think that's very important now
this question that you brought up about
antibodies and testing and then
reboosting
i don't know that there's a lot of
science behind that it's a strategy that
hasn't been studied very well but if hey
if they want to do this
yeah yeah it's just because we don't and
i'll tell you why
um we don't fully understand that
the antibody levels directly correlate
to immunity because the immunity is
multifocal there's a t cell mediated
immunity that doesn't have to do with
antibodies
the we've measured antibodies declining
in people but what we don't measure is
their b
cell clonal response that when you get
reinfected the b cells which are the
memory part they just start spitting out
anybody again the clone army gets
reactivated
so i think it's more complex than simply
measuring titers but time will tell and
research will
bear it out okay so in that case how do
you feel about
them suggesting that people who have
already had coved
get the vaccine isn't the point of
catching something like
measles that you don't have to get
vaccinated again like right
what's going on here this is a great
question so um
measles a good example measles vaccine
and measles and rna virus just like
coronavirus measles vaccine is 96
percent
or higher effective in people who've had
both shots
and there is uh you know they're the six
months apart mmr
vaccination it's remarkable and it's
lifelong for most people and it's what
they call
sterilizing immunity meaning once you're
immune
that [ __ ] can't can't infect you at all
um it'd be very hard very very hard so
that that's one extreme another extreme
is something like influenza vaccine
where
the virus mutates yeah every year and
these surface antigens that we're
targeting with the vaccine
change every year and we have to hope we
predict it right and so on and that's
why
influenza vaccine is you know 50 60
effective in some years
sometimes lower because we get the match
wrong so that's the other extreme now
where coronavirus sits
is in an unknown area because we've
never made a vaccine against coronavirus
we know coronavirus mutates we have
these variants they're less
they're less neutralized by the
antibodies we measure with current
vaccines but that doesn't tell us
whether the vaccines actually are
effective against them what tells us is
real world data which is showing us
that they are quite effective against
what we care about which is
severe disease and death so the debate
then is how long will it last do we need
a booster
if will the variants require new
boosters and the answer is maybe we
don't know
and how long will they last well we know
they last at least six months in the
terms of the pfizer vaccine because
that's how far they've been measured out
with very robust immunity
people my friend paul offit who's one of
the experts on this thinks that the
immunity is at least a year
probably longer and that um
if we need a booster it's because a new
variants have emerged that will require
an update but that's not a big deal
and it probably won't take a two shot
booster it'll probably be one the other
question you asked was the
should people who've had covid get
vaccinated was that the question
yeah yeah um this is such
a good and nuanced and complicated
question because anyone who says they
have the answer to this
is operating from a data set that's
incomplete and they're just making [ __ ]
up out of their ass
so this is what i think about this
i think that in a perfect world with
perfect resources
everyone who's had covet will get
vaccinated and this is why
it appears particularly with the mrna
vaccines that the
and again this this contradicts
something i said earlier which is that
the antibody response itself is maybe
not the best measure of how
robust immunity is but the correlates of
immunity
are stronger in people who've had both
doses of the
mrna vaccines than they are in naturally
infected people
there's other early data that kind of
says
people who've been naturally infected if
they've been vaccinated
tend to resist reinfection with variants
maybe more
so there's stuff that still is being
studied that would say
okay maybe there's a good reason to go
ahead and get that vaccine now the
question is do you get
one or both doses if you're doing mrna
and is one enough and we
just we there's some data that says
maybe it is but we don't have enough
data to be able to answer it
conclusively so again it gets back to
you
what is your risk sort of determination
if you understand okay
you're you know michaela maybe where
you're like 28 something
um young person younger
even younger i like that 29 i'm 29. damn
it
you know yeah i know i'm almost 30. it
hurts me too more
i mean well you look about 16. so you
have that going for you but see
crazy this is the thing i've always the
zoom blur
people are people are always like what
kind of beauty filter are you using
zubin because you're like
you know turning 48 this month and i'm
like it's called lighting
and a really nice camera with a with a
soft lens because
if you see me in person i look like the
[ __ ] keeper so
i need a soft lens yeah you need you
know anyway
we'll we'll definitely talk camera tech
because uh it's
okay yes please yours looks great so oh
what were we talking about i derailed
myself on this oh risk risk for the
personal so if you're gonna get the
actual covered vaccine you have to look
at yourself and go well okay i'm a young
person
i had covid it was pretty mild i didn't
i don't know about your case i'm just
projecting it was a mild thing i didn't
die
um i didn't become a long-haul or
whatever that is and
nothing else happened so do i need to
get vaccinated now
probably not well maybe i live with an
old person that's at high risk and
they've been vaccinated so maybe now
they're at lower risk so
what should i do so it's it's a tough
calculation but everyone has to make it
for themselves i think
avoiding the question i like it okay um
no that's fair though that's a fair
response can we quickly cover i've
two questions can you describe what an
mrna
vaccine is and do we have any studies of
other mrna vaccines
excellent question so the technology has
been around
in some form been studied for at least a
decade or two
and the idea is that messenger rna is
this
very you know unique
naturally made component of cellular
metabolism where
you have your dna in your in the nucleus
of the cell that encodes all your
genetic information what's amazing is
every single cell of your body
has the entire genome that could
basically create a whole human
and it gets philosophical and you go wow
every cell of us is a hole
and a part of a whole in and of itself
and that that's
spiritually quite interesting so there's
that
the dna is transcribed into
mrna by an apparatus that does this and
it spits out a little copy like a little
transcript
that's a slightly different compound
that then leaves the nucleus goes to the
cytoplasm of the cell where it goes
through a machinery
with ribosomes and so on where that
messenger rna is like an email from the
nucleus
it tells the cellular machinery this is
the protein you need to make
and when that protein is made from the
mrna it undergoes this complex folding
process and packaging in the
you know endoplasmic reticulum and all
the golgi apparatus and all that stuff
you learned in high school biology and
then promptly forgot
um that stuff then is how we make
proteins so the way the mrna vaccines
work is we hijacked this
aspect of normal cellular function we
said okay
we want the body to see the spike
protein the business end of this virus
and recognize it because that's the end
that binds to ace2 receptors and
allows the virus to enter our cells if
we can surround that area with
antibodies that's
one way to knock the virus out to
neutralize it that's why they use the
term neutralizing antibodies
antibodies are simply proteins that
recognize the shape of what they're
attacking and surround it and bind to it
in different spots
so if the spike protein has these
different locations neutralizing
antibodies recognize and bind stick to
it like a lock and a key and then that
neutralizes
the virus either by preventing it from
binding to cells or
by flagging it so when when you have
these antibodies
there are other cells help or t cells
killer killer cells
that then recognize that this thing's
been flagged and actually
destroy the cell that
is infected by it so because the cells
that have
that are infected by coronavirus they
display this spike protein on its
surface kind of like hey guys
look at this is this right am i supposed
to be making this
and the helper t cells go oh hell no and
they
they they can trigger a cascade that
causes death of that cell
so it's like hey suicide yourself for
the good or the of the
of the rest all right so what you want
to do then is
prime the immune system because in order
to spin up this response it takes time
and that's why you get sick
the virus is replicating you feel like
[ __ ] because your immune system is
starting to generate cytokines and
interferons and things like that that
make you feel all the symptoms that
people
complain about both with coronavirus and
with the vaccine
that helps the immune system function
fever actually helps
the immune system function that's why i
tell people don't treat your fever if
you can avoid it when you're getting the
vaccine
even when you're sick if you can avoid
it unless it's just killing you
or it's very high and the doctor tells
you you need to so so that being said
the way the mrna vaccine then teaches
your immune system
this in advance so that it can respond
quickly is
we take that email that mrna and we
create it in a lab
and we say okay we know the sequence of
the
mrna that is going to tell the cell how
to make the spike protein
let's just put it in a little package
because and this is important
mrna is so transient it's so ephemeral
it's so easily
broken down that once it's in the
cytoplasm it's gone
in in no time at all once it makes the
protein it it gets broke
broken down if you inject it into an arm
by itself it just goes it just crumbles
because it's not designed
to survive outside of cells so you wrap
it
in a little fat bubble they call it the
lipid nanoparticle because they want to
get nerdy about it but really it's just
a little
bubble of oil that they've designed that
allows it then
to merge with the bubble of oil that is
our cell
because our cell membrane is basically
like a little oily bubble
that keeps the inside and the outside
separate so once it merges
the rna enters that cell and it does the
same thing that
mrna always does it gets transcribed
into protein the body makes the spike
protein it shows it on the surface
all our immune system goes hey what's
that and starts
finding clonal b cells to go no that's
not okay and spins up a response that's
why
eight hours after the second dose or so
when i got moderna
i felt the worst i felt in
decades like and i've been sick here and
there right i'm a doctor i get sick from
patients and stuff
i was knocked on my ass with fevers
muscles aches chills
rigers headache brain fog everything and
what's fascinating michaela is that
this was the first time i could go
because i've had every vaccine in the
book
this is the first time i could go oh
[ __ ]
like this is what the immune response
feels like
minus the infection itself and so every
time i've had a flu or a cold and i feel
like crap
95 of those symptoms are your own immune
system
going ape [ __ ] and the other five
percent are the viral replication
the cough the phlegm the
you know the constant hacking and i
didn't have any of that because
there's no virus in this vaccine it's
just the spike protein so it doesn't do
all that stuff so
it's really quite fascinating so then it
gives your body a masters tutorial in
how to make this uh protein the next
time when the virus comes it's like it
has no chance because we spin up the
clone army right away
and knock it out of commission that's
kind of what
my experience with kovid was like like
it was 18 days
ah it wasn't that bad i had a mild fever
like
37.6 for a couple days i could feel a
wheeze and i was like uh oh
what does this happen but then nothing
happened um and i was
off and on like achy for 18 days
um but i didn't have like i wasn't
sneezed was i i was a little bit sneezy
but i was a tiny bit sneezy but it
wasn't that bad my nanny
had one day of an upset stomach my
stomach was upset actually
that was one of the big symptoms as my
digestion was upset my kid got
the rash like the covid rash she got a
rash on her hands and her feet
uh my husband had similar symptoms to me
but it wasn't like
it wasn't the worst i've well i've felt
pretty bad in the last 10 years though
so the worst i felt is not a good
comparison
uh what are the other are there other
mrna
vaccines that we would be uh familiar
with
not really no these are sort of that's
what's freaking people out
commercial ones right now you know i
think for ebola
um i'm forgetting the exact mechanism of
that vaccine but again that's not a
vaccine that everybody gets right that's
one of those like esoteric vaccines and
um so and so it freaks people out yes
and this is how i think about that
because
listen i was super skeptical dude
because i thought this whole thing was
politicized from the beginning like is
the vaccine
going to be politicized yeah and it has
been so
but what's interesting is it yeah it's
been politicized in both ways so when
trump was
pushing the vaccines everyone was like
oh my god it's going to be
trumpified and it's going to come out
too early and they're going to push it
and everybody all the left was scared
and i was like i'm not got no vaccine
now that you know biden's spinning up
vaccines the right is like hell no i'm
not taking this biden vaccine and it's
like well
guys like let's just look at the actual
data here and and
understand that my conclusion being
skeptical so i've made multiple videos
over the course of the pandemic and you
can see
i i i'm just like well okay if this
thing
happens in less than a year i'm going to
be shocked and then we see in less than
a year that the trial data comes out and
i'm like now wait a minute so then i
i call up paul offit the expert who sits
on the fda advisory committee he comes
on my show and we talk about it
and he's like they did it i mean they
they actually got enough trial
participants and this
so this is why it was possible to happen
so fast and why we can reassure people
that this is not
insane because boy it feels wrong
doesn't it
like intuition says time period
yeah yeah how do you know people aren't
having trouble having kids
in a year didn't that happen with
gardasil like people had some issues
there after a while
so that that so that yeah that that's
what i'm trying to do
yeah yeah the answer is no but the
answer is there is a public fear
contagion with gardasil
that has spread a lot of misinformation
about gardasil and
um and it's interesting how it happens
because it's the same thing
especially for a vaccine that has some
stigma associated with
oh are we going to be encouraging sexual
intercourse by giving
an hpv vaccine and so on and we're
giving it to our young
girls first and there's a lot of
societal stigma around young girls so it
just became a real thing
um but the mrna vaccine is interesting
we have decades of research that builds
you to this point people had worked on
it but it was never commercially
done and the reason is in order to do a
vaccine trial successfully you have to
enroll tens of thousands of people
you have to randomize and double blind
and placebo control it
you have to have a prevalence of the
disease that's enough that you're going
to actually show a difference
between the placebo group and this group
so that normally takes years
because the prevalence of the disease is
so low that
to show an effect you've got to follow
patients for years and
it takes forever to recruit patients
because people don't really want to be
part of a vaccine trial typically it's
like
why would i want to be part of a you
know respiratory syncytial virus trial
it's like i don't care about that
and then comes along covid everyone's
[ __ ] their pants
everyone wants to be a part of the trial
instantly they enroll 40 000 people you
know per trial
it's a piece of cake to enroll people so
now you have the people now do you have
the prevalence of the disease well [ __ ]
we do the disease is all over the place
everybody's getting it so we can
actually
get numbers quickly uh
and so you end up doing the business end
of the trial which is the phase
three trial in humans that looks at both
safety
and efficacy that's really what you want
you end up doing it in three
three four months because you can
and all the government red tape says
okay we're going to take the financial
risk away because we're going to buy the
vaccine whether it works or not so the
pharma companies who are [ __ ]
are like well then fine let's do this
because they're scared about losing
money right
so they take that off the table and on
top of that
this is the first vaccine where
everybody's skin is in the game because
they're like well
i have a date with this vaccine like all
the doctors are like well i'm going to
be getting this vaccine so
it better [ __ ] be safe and effective
so they're looking at the data and
they're skeptical and so
the people who care most about this are
all of us for once it's not like you
know
any other vaccine almost right and so
for that reason
uh when you look at the data then you go
okay this is compelling now look at the
if you worry that the system fails like
maybe we're wrong about this look at
astrazeneca
this is a situation where the primary
the primary trial data did not show
rare rare rare events of blood clotting
world data did they're still super rare
but when you when you have a trial of 25
million people you pick up very rare
things
so you do catch them people do take it
seriously they do respond they do
investigate they do pause campaigns for
better force
they can still make a case and say risk
and benefit says you should still get
the vaccine but then people can make a
decision based on
what's been known about the vaccine and
so that gets to the point if you don't
coerce these vaccines
you let you educate people and you let
them make decisions
right okay so that that's what i was
going to
actually one comment first do you know
of khan academy
that's how so i took sciences and
and calculus just murdered me and like
that youtube channel
got me through it and your explanation
of how a vaccine works
like brought me back to cell biology but
it was very well done
visually like i could imagine it so
that was very entertaining i can see why
you're popular
that as nick cage would say that's high
praise
like that's really kind of you so the
con con
is a legendary thing my kids use khan
academy and and teaching
yeah trying to teach without stuff
in other words without the visual props
means you have to paint a picture in
your own head and then communicate it
it's it's a challenge but it's also a
flow state authentic joy
if you can get in the pocket with that
and sometimes i do and sometimes i don't
and when i don't i hear about it from
fans they're like
yeah could we have slides and then other
times they're like
yeah yeah yeah okay
um okay so then we were talking about
you shouldn't coerce people so
um how do you feel about this a vaccine
passport
that seem i don't know a lot about it i
do know that texas said no
i don't know what florida said but i
like i think new york and some other
places are
seriously considering this um how do you
feel about that
yeah this is another great topic to look
at from an
alt middle perspective an integral
perspective and go
okay what's involved what's at play here
and why does our own moral matrix
actually determine how we're going to
respond to this
so a vaccine passport is simply saying
the following it's saying by showing
evidence of you being vaccinated
having previous infection having
antibodies whatever you want to use to
define
a green card right like i get a pass
you can then allow certain restrictions
to
evaporate much more rapidly so for
example a restaurant could
fill its room back to back no social
distancing
with vaccinated people who have a
vaccine passport um
you could fill a plane with vaccinated
people and maybe turn take the masks off
you could
uh allow travel into countries that have
been otherwise restrictive with a
vaccine
passport you could go to sporting events
and fill a stadium with people who have
a vaccine passport okay
well in theory this sounds cool from the
stance of
protection of people so if you have a
care versus harm
moral sensibility that is is prominent
in you you go well that don't sounds
good liberty versus oppression moral
palette says wait a minute now
you want me to show you my papers so
that i can do what i ought to be doing
anyways which is being
that's me yeah [ __ ] you everyone me too
exactly i mean you and i are very
similar we have this oppositional
defiant disorder it's like don't you
don't tell me what to do
and i won't tell you what to do uh but i
will tell you what i think
uh but yeah and and so that that is very
strong in a lot of people and they just
immediately like an immune response
reject the idea
now what's interesting is there are
other aspects to this
and that is equity and justice aspects
so say
say you have a more liberal palette of
um fairness versus
cheating and care versus harm you can
look at this and go
wait so you're saying that rich people
who can get access to the vaccines
faster
older people who get access to the
vaccines faster are now preferentially
able to go
and enjoy life whereas the rest of us
who haven't gotten the vaccine who don't
have access who are
say maybe in canada who haven't had
access yet we can't
[ __ ] off right so already there's an
inequity
in that and it it it then further
solidifies the zoom
let's re okay and now i'm editorializing
but so those are the kind of
issues and we have kind of vaccine
passports for certain international
travel
like i think some countries require
yellow fever and different different uh
vaccinations but that's a yes the subtle
thing right now
this is what i think by by talking about
vaccine passports
we're distracting ourselves from the
real issue which is just get as many
people vaccinated at who are willing to
be vaccinated as you can and the
pandemic's over
let's focus on that having to dangle a
vaccine passport
is only going to help rich people and
people who have
quick access to vaccines all you're
going to do is double down on the [ __ ]
ups we've already done
which is hurting poor people closing
schools destroying a generation of kids
who are vulnerable
and helping people like you and i who
are part of the democracy who can make a
ton of
uh we can make a living and continue to
work sitting at home
while tisking uh uh people for not
wearing five masks
um and then oh we but we have a vaccine
passport so i'm on the beach without a
mask now
[ __ ] off you know it really does trigger
that kind of
response
okay i'm curious what you think what do
i have um
i don't i don't
like the idea of putting like anything
on anybody or forcing anybody to do
anything
even though i know that that would
probably not end up well
you need some guidelines but i'd like to
like like you said get the proper
information out
like this fear-mongering
is so nauseating especially in ontario
it's so bad like our um
our premier has full-on said that going
against any of the
any of these co-vid lockdowns is
political suicide
and it was it's like well people are
actually killing themselves in lockdown
like they're actually dying it's not
just they're
like it's not just political suicide for
some people um
but i'm yeah i'm not i'm i'm not into
i'm not into that but i also have a bit
of a bias which i'm fully aware of
because
i was so sick as a kid that i've spoken
with specialists who've said
you could have this could have been an
adverse reaction to a vaccine
we don't know it's unlikely but it could
have played a role because i had like i
had arthritis at two
right like um so i'm like i already have
a bias about
putting anything into my like anything
into my body especially now that i'm
healthy
so then i think well if i don't want it
then i shouldn't force other people
to do this and i have like i have
members my family who've gone to get the
vaccine who've been thrilled about it
they haven't even noticed
right in in canada and they feel better
and they were at a higher risk and
that's totally fine i'm
like i said i'm here in dubai and most
people are vaccinated and
people are out in the open and things
are better but i don't like the idea of
government mandating where people go
dependent on what they've
injected into their body it freaks me
out yeah
let's dig into that a little bit because
i think that's important um your
experience
as a child you've been through hell you
know i've watched
your videos and videos with your dad and
and you've been through hell recently
you've been through hell
as a child and juvenile rheumatoid
arthritis is not
a [ __ ] joke it is as you i'm
preaching to the choir here so we won't
get into that but i'll say this
your search for meaning why did this
happen
is the most human of all reactions
and in fact my friend marty mccary who's
often on the news talking about kovit
from a standpoint that we stand at like
you know let's
move let's stop the fearmongering and
let's actually do the right thing for
the most people
without compelling anything and and um
very smart guy johns hopkins
public health uh policy guy he
says that he's a cancer surgeon and he
says the first
question about that he gets when he
gives a diagnosis of cancer is
why did this happen to me what hap what
did i do
what what happened and it's the same
with autism it's the same with arthritis
with autoimmune people have to ask the
question
was it this was it something that could
have been done and where's my locus of
control could i have
done something differently and these are
if you're not asking these questions
you're not a human being and if you're
not concerned about them you're not a
human being and i think
i've fallen into this trap as a as a
sciency guy
of judging you know anti-vaxxers by like
well they're just crazy
you know diluted lunatics and the truth
is now
yeah it's easy to do right because well
some are but i mean there are lunatics
everywhere
that's true so i think there's this one
percent of really truly deluded and they
get no quarter from me and i
ridicule them mercilessly but it's folks
like folks like yourself who would have
rational concerns and go well okay could
it have been this and
there's not good data that says that it
ever has been in other words you're
the actual virus that you're often
vaccinating against is more likely to
cause
autoimmune effects like for example the
disease guillain-barre syndrome
which is an autoimmune reaction where
your
yeah your nerves become demyelinated you
lose this
it's almost like stripping the
electrical wires of their insulation and
everything just gloms and so you you get
an ascending paralysis
it can be fatal you can stop breathing
but often you can support people through
it with
ventilators and so on and you get better
it's associated with certain vaccines
like influenza vaccine and so people go
oh my god the vaccine is
associated with this thing but then you
look at actually
what happens when you're naturally
infected with influenza
you're like something like 10 times more
likely to get guillain-barre from
natural
influenza infections so in a way the
vaccine actually reduces the net risk of
getting
guillain-barre but it's these are very
hard concepts to think about
and so it's natural to be frightened the
other thing michaela is
are you are you at all frightened of
needles
no i've been injecting myself since i
was seven
right like it's really not
yeah it's never been a thing for you oh
yeah at the beginning it was
for like 10 years but that's because i
was injecting myself that's way worse
than getting a needle
yeah it always had for diabetics same
thing so
there's some data that the way we do
vaccines in kids
we take a four to six year old kid
we strap them down two nurses come
inject multiple arms at once
and because the schedule of vaccines
actually is
really kind of designed very
intentionally that that's how you
generate the best immune response and so
on
but what there's some data emerging i
had a doctor named amy baxter on the
show talking about this that
in that and your dad might appreciate
this because he talks about human
development and especially kids in
piaget
and these stages of development in that
stage of development between four and
six like when you're younger than four
you don't form very solid memories
you're you're sort of pre-operational
you're not you're not really so you can
inject
an infant with hella vaccines and they
don't remember needle fear or anything
like that
four to six the kid is in an op you know
kind of
concrete operational phase where they
they
they see this vaccine happening they're
terrified
they don't understand abstractly why
this helps them
and they associate this with deep fear
that then transitions as they grow older
into an
unconscious deep fear of medical
intervention like that
especially needles and then when they're
older and they have rational faculties
their unconscious emotional faculty
still is terrified
and then tells the reason because reason
is just our press secretary it's not
actually in charge of anything it's
the emotions press secretary it
basically says um
let me find data to support my
unconscious fear here and then you find
plenty online that says well vaccines
can cause this and maybe they cause that
maybe they cause this and maybe because
that you know what i think
i'm not going to get vaccinated whereas
the deep root underlying that
is you were traumatized you know by the
medical intervention where we strapped
you down and gave you multiple
injections at once
so it's very nuanced and it's an
individual thing and that's why i'm with
you that coercion of this
is gonna backfire it's it's never gonna
work you have to
educate and do it from a place of love
and let people make decision now
for school vaccinations it's tricky
because you can harm people who are
unable to be vaccinated because of their
health status and they could die if your
unvaccinated child gives them measles or
something so maybe you say well then for
public schools
you have to be vaccinated if you're not
then you have to either home school or
go to a private school and that i'm on
the fence about you know more
um so that's my thinking on that
yeah that totally makes sense um for me
i actually wasn't
afraid of the needles until i gave them
to myself
and then the medication was extremely
nauseating
so i'd get nauseous so when i started
getting nauseous after i was giving
myself my needles then i
then i got an aversion to it before that
i guess i don't know why
um maybe i'm brave but i wasn't i
remember getting vaccinated when i was a
kid and it didn't bug me i was like yeah
in both arms and this one three at once
i don't know when that was but uh
it did i didn't get an aversion until
the nausea started from the medication
but i can see how that could happen to
people nausea is such a
um biopsychosocial thing you know
and what i mean by that everything is
everything's biopsychosocial means we
have a biological component there's a
psychological component and there's the
social component of it
and nausea is particularly in in
medicine we have this term
supratentorial
the tentorium is a barrier in the brain
that separates
the the anatomical structures of our
cortex which are the like what we think
is our rational reasoning all that
and the lower structures which are
emotion and that sort of thing
and and and and more um not even emotion
more like our autonomic structures like
breathing and that stuff that happens
in the background and we say something
super tentorial when we're trying to say
that's psychologically driven nausea is
a great example when you
see the needle and you've associated it
with vomiting before like chemotherapy
people they just see the bag
and they get so nauseous yeah i see it
it it's and
we evolved that i mean it's important
protection mechanism it's a disgust
response and it keeps us safe from
poisons and so on and but boy it's hard
when you're a kid i mean i
i gotta say this like when i heard your
story i was like just outpouring of
compassion because i couldn't
imagine that's why i couldn't do
pediatrics the suffering of children
is beyond the pale like um yeah so
that you've come out this strong kind of
you know intelligent articulate person
who can talk about issues and knows who
you are
that's not the standard outcome right
yeah
it's a result of resiliency and finding
meaning and suffering and so on which
i'm sure
your dad could speak to better than i
can but you know kudos it's
not easy to do thank you
thank you i'm tougher now um and that
that needle fear definitely went away
as soon as i stopped giving myself the
medication i was like um
i could poke myself like i i did too
just out of curiosity which is [ __ ] up
but like
i was like ah it's gone it's gone as
soon as i didn't like
anyway anyway
yeah yeah but it wasn't fun it does make
me
extremely skeptical about anything
medical because as soon as i did go
why is this happening to me and then
searched around a little bit i was like
oh well
okay i could have changed things and i
would have stopped this
that's not fun like that made me so
angry for like i'm still angry
but i was i was angry enough that i was
getting panic attacks when i went into
hospitals
which never like that never happened i
was always i was always okay and then as
soon as
diet reversed all my symptoms and all my
symptoms went away and i went off all of
my medications
um i had a phobia of hospitals for about
i had a phobia of hospitals until i had
to bring my dad
to hospitals and i had to force myself
to go into the hospital
to go with him and then i was having
panic attacks in those hospitals
and eventually i desensitized myself and
now the panic attacks are gone
but but yeah it's been it's been a wild
ride
it's been a very wild ride nothing that
you said is
is unusual or
i mean it it all makes sense you know i
i one of the earliest memories i have is
of being tied down by a bunch of nurses
so that they could
give me vaccines and check my blood
pressure and
the feeling i remember this my mom was
in the room it was at her hospital
because she
my both my parents are doctors yeah so
they they took me to their own hospital
tie me down
uh the things squeezing on me i'm
screaming and punching and
and nurses are having to like restrain
me because i'm violent right
and um now so when i first started
training as a
as a physician and i would enter a
hospital i would have this like
surge of like weird adrenaline i
couldn't figure it out and anytime
anyone checks my blood pressure that
isn't me my blood pressure is elevated
and when i check it it's it's low and i
realize it's this
conditioning you know it it really is
and we forget that children
are conditioned it's how we evolved we
we
we incorporate this stuff and still we
until we make it conscious until we see
it
or desensitize it like you did by going
in the hospital facing the fear this is
why all this stuff about ptsd
i need to avoid triggers no you need to
face with help don't do it alone it's
hard
but you you that's why we don't have
safe we don't make safe spaces we don't
ban words we don't
uh coddle children we we
make them face this stuff with help and
love
period that's what i think we ought to
be doing with love
yeah i agree which is why the coercion
doesn't work
when i um when when i first started
having those like i went it
surprised me right i went to a hospital
i had a panic attack and i was like
what because there wasn't any it was
like a physical there wasn't even a lot
of mental there
right i just had this physical response
and i talked to my dad and my dad said
that's a completely reasonable response
given what happened to you
yeah but you need to desensitize
yourself because you're probably going
to need to
end up you know you're probably going to
need a hospital at some point which was
like way sooner for other people than i
wanted it to be but uh
it's definitely interesting yeah that
was very interesting
you're smart uh no i just talked i'm
still super
no no you're smart i'm still very
skeptical but
but those are excellent explanations you
should be skeptical
if one person can convince you in a
conversation about something then you're
probably not skeptical enough you need
to continue to
get in as much data as you can and then
you have to feel into it too and go okay
well my intuition is one thing
often our intuition is wrong but what is
it telling me about me
that is resisting and how how can i then
recognize the bias and still understand
how to make a good decision for me and
the good decision may still be well you
don't want to get vaccinated fine
then maybe that's a good decision for
you especially given your risks and so
on you know
um are you on any sort of and you don't
have to answer this because it's a
medical question but are you on any
immunosuppressing
medications that would put you at risk
for infection
no but i i was until i was 23. i
literally put all of my
symptoms into remission i have no
arthritis and
this is actually really exciting i could
never
put my hands on the ground with my wrist
flat
like so um i used to get off the ground
when i was a kid like this
because of the arthritis in my wrist
yeah i did my first push-up
in my entire life with my wrists like
this
yesterday i could do that wow for the
first time in my entire life
yeah that's really exciting i almost
cried like i really almost cried out
it is emotional it's emotional and and
the thing is
you know and again i think about your
story and and the kind of suffering
you know when i saw the interview you
did with your um with your dad
the the long one where you were talking
about his
hospitalizations and the path you went
through i mean that was so
affecting not just because of your dad
who you know i've admired
and his struggle is is
you've documented it and it was looking
at you
and going wow she's been through
hell on all these sides and yet isn't
insane yet i mean she's close to him on
video
on video yeah my husband today sent me
a meme and it's this duck and it's just
paddling
and they're on a waterfall and he's like
this is you
so on video but thank you but but
you have to accept that listen you have
to accept that the thing is you're
you're the type of patient that many of
us doctors
are terrified of because you you've been
through all this
so you have all this collected trauma
you have a complex medical condition
that we don't fully understand but we
think we do but we want to feel like we
do so we reduce it to receptors and
pills and so on
but we've not seen the full
biopsychosocial thing because it's
complicated and we don't get paid for
that we don't have the time for that
we're
hurting ourselves be you know because
we're suffering in a system that doesn't
value connection it values throughput
and
for that reason you're a challenge to us
that hurts
us morally because we want to help you
and we know we can't and so we don't
have the tools resources and autonomy to
do it
so it becomes this mutual suffering
cascade
that then someone like you will then go
i need help so i'm going to go
and find it and then you happen to find
a very restrictive diet that eliminated
most components of the diet that then
allowed you to feel better and for you
that worked
brilliantly and now you have to suffer
with having that same diet all the time
which i
imagine you've gotten used to or yeah
not really
it's not like you're like i'm on
freaking like two foods
or three a little bit more now but like
you don't get used to it
you still look at cookies when they put
they put freaking little tiny nice
little cookies at the table everywhere
here
and it's much better like no i don't eat
that like it's fine
but you know there's a little bit of me
that's like that cookie looked really
good
i i did keto for eight months and uh
i got to enjoy it and i got a six-pack
and i was like this is dope
and then i realized i wasn't able to eat
with my family at all and they were
starting to yeah
it's social issue bio psychology this is
social yes yes
aspect it really is tough but but see
i'm sure for in your social circle
having you
well is well worth not having
the opportunity to eat a cookie or a
birthday cake with you right
so there are these yeah sort of trade
although it's still
one thing though yeah i would wonder
about with yours since you did such a
restrictive it's a meat only diet yeah
yeah but i went down i did like paleo
and then that worked really really well
a very restricted paleo and then i
and then it stopped working um and then
it was meat and greens and then it was
meat and then i've been on meat for
three and a half years
and i'm just i'm getting better now but
yeah
would you consider adding things back
slowly to try to see which elements you
could
safely add that's the goal i mean i
counsel
people kind of on facebook for free and
it's not medical advice
counseling um people on this diet and
i've seen a lot of success
with reintroducing foods so it seems to
have a component of gut healing
and then when that happens like a lot of
these people have been on a ton of
medication for a really long time
and then they reduce their diet they go
to all meat and then
a lot of these people especially if
they're not as sick as me
go on to reintroduce things and don't
have symptoms
usually they stay without you know
grains and kind of keep to paleo if they
have
sicknesses but the goal is not to be
restricted like this forever
right right and you know yeah you said
um you know gut microbiome i think is a
big component of this stuff that we
don't fully understand
i think you know what you eat that's i
think that's part of the reason why
people who
uh use a lot of artificial sweeteners
there has been data that that does alter
your microbiome and
and maybe introduces insulin resistance
so even though you you know you're
downing all these diet drinks doesn't
mean you're not affecting your gut flora
that then makes you
actually resistant to insulin it's
almost like giving you diabetes a
different way
so there's all kinds of stuff we don't
understand and one of the things about
your diet and again i'm not advocating
any one diet no i've done videos about
this where i say
diet is a personal you have to
individually customize it for you
and figure out what works for you but
people treat it as a religion right you
in these circles is like no you must be
paleo or keto is the only way and it's
like well no for me
or people are carnivores and what
happens
to my carnivora you get within the
carnivore community you get people are
supposed to only eat meat
but so that that's a that's a big one
and i think that there are
historical periods where people probably
ate a lot of meat
but that doesn't mean that you can't
eat blueberries without getting
arthritis it it's
it's really interesting because
everybody's physiology is different some
people respond to a vegan diet so well
i get fat on a vegan diet but i do well
with mediterranean say but i've had to
try every diet to try to figure out what
works for me
and i used to be very carb averse and
now i find that complex carbs actually
will fill me up
in a way that allows me to eat less
overall but it has to be the right thing
like whole wheat bread with nuts and
so it's very unique and
and the thing is you have to find it for
yourself but diet often evolves into a
kind of a
identity and a religion that can be can
be detrimental when it's looked at that
way
your diet is interesting because what it
does is it's whole real food
so you're cutting out by nature of it
all the processed stuff that's what
veganism certain veganism and certain
keto has in common it often cuts out
fake food which makes it although oreos
i believe are vegan
so there's that there's that yeah the
diet i'm on gets a lot of criticism for
being like well if you just
cut out processed foods and on like seed
oils and all these things you'd be fine
but
i did that for like two years two and a
half years and then
i was eating like it was good i had like
apples fruit
salad sweet potatoes fish meat like a
bunch of things and then
it stopped working after after here's a
clue i went on a round of really intense
antibiotics
and then i couldn't tolerate the carbs
anymore so i'm like it's got to be
microbiome
microbiome related yeah yeah it said
we're such complex systems you know i
had a guy on my show yesterday
federico fajine he designed the world's
first commercial microprocessor for
intel that basically now
is this and he's an old italian guy and
he comes on here
and he has awakened to this idea that
humans are not machines because he's
worked on artificial intelligence for
like 30 years
and what he determined is we're these
complex
quantum classical systems and that's a
fancy way of saying
we exist in the in the quantum
probability world that's very infinite
and crazy where consciousness is and
then we are also a symbol
that exists in this classical world
where we look like stuff that's very
simple and deterministic and we can
predict how it behaves
but because a human cell is not just a
machine
it's this quantum classical interface
that is driven by consciousness itself
you can't reduce things to simple
answers right yeah the microbiomes there
those are living creatures living in us
that are cells part holes of them
themselves and we ignore it all we try
to reduce it in medicine because we can
we go well in medical school they taught
us about receptors and gates and
channels and drugs
so a more integral perspective is a
holistic perspective and saying well no
it's actually all these things that's
why
patients like you and i refer to you as
a patient just because i'm now i'm
talking to my audience right so
patients like you instead of us shutting
down
and going we don't understand she must
be crazy she's only eating meat
is it the medications we gave her that
made her crazy enough to only eat meat
that's literally how
a lot of healthcare professionals think
right now no
you're you're this complex system that's
trying to figure out what's best for you
and you're trying to teach us something
not just about you but about other
patients like you and we ought to be
there
open and listening with compassion and
also humility
but it's hard because we are ourselves
in trials
yeah i would like some carnivore
carnivore trials
i'll join that one long as good yeah
well i think that could
that could be how will you know it
hasn't been done like keto studies are
done why is there no carnivore study yet
you know what be interesting is to do it
have the placebo group be all fake meat
and tell them it's real meat like
you're eating like the impossible burger
the thing is you tell in a second
[Music]
yeah you can tell in a second that
wouldn't be fair that wouldn't be fair
uh okay thank you so much for coming on
i would love
to talk more but it's been an hour
that was very interesting thank you uh
where can people find you online
if they don't follow you already so
we're on all the platforms
our biggest is facebook but if you just
go to zdogmd.com2gs
because one is necessary but not
sufficient to be a gangster
uh you can find everything and join our
you know supporter groups
subscribe to our videos we have a
podcast version if you don't like
watching my face
but it's important to spread the word
about um
thinking rationally and clearly and
compassionately
that was fun thanks again thank you
[Music]
you